okay I want to sort of do a reset of
2019 for the David Pakman show and then
maybe more importantly I want to hear
from you about what you want from us in
2020 really important stuff particularly
when there are so many forces working
against independent media in many ways
2019 was an awesome year for the David
Pakman show a few numbers for you
podcast downloads were up 71 percent 20
19 over 20 18 71% an incredible number
YouTube views were up 29% we had 93
million views in 2018 up to a hundred
and twenty-one million views in 2019
very solid YouTube subscribers notably
up 88 percent we started 2019 with four
hundred and eighteen thousand
subscribers and we ended 2019 with seven
hundred and eighty nine thousand
subscribers a big big year as far as
YouTube subscriptions go also paid
memberships up 86 percent I said a
couple weeks ago when that racist Kansas
troll called in and said David your
membership program is an embarrassment
it's just not gonna work it's not
happening paid memberships and
membership started in 2010 okay so we
had 2010 2011 2012 2013 you get the
point during 2019 almost doubling paid
memberships up 86 percent now it's not
all gingersnaps and waterfalls areas of
difficulty continue to be the
monetization of our content on various
platforms YouTube being a top one so my
question to you is what do you want in
2020 do you want more international
politics do you want more live streams
of special events the way we did over
the last couple of months with
impeachment hearings and debates so on
and so forth are you interested in more
long-form pieces if so what subjects are
interesting to you is there a particular
type of election coverage that you do
want or you don't want how often should
we be talked
about polling for example how often
should we be talking about whatever I
want to hear from you about this do you
want the show cancelled altogether do
you want me to quit and turn the show
over to producer Pat it will be the
David Pakman show no longer hosted by
David Pakman are you interested in us
coming to you from primary States on
election days last year or last election
for example on primary day in 2016 in
New Hampshire we were talking to voters
in was it Manchester or Keene I don't
even remember it must have in Manchester
I don't remember where I was but it was
crazy that's something that we are
looking at doing so the show has always
been guided and directed by the audience
so I want to hear from you what are you
interested in seeing for 2020 what do
you think will provide value what do you
think will be useful in that other media
outlets are not doing it and if you
don't want anything to change don't
worry the show will remain the show I
always want to iterate see what we can
do better see what we can tweak but the
show will basically remain the David
Pakman show one last question on this
are there other platforms you believe
the David Pakman show should be on we
get a lot of invitations to put the show
on you platforms and I will test somehow
and some don't work out notably Jordan
Peterson's think spot is one that did
not work out for us in 2019
there is a new platform that were on
that is actually really exciting it's
called a library it's lb ry TV we've
quietly added our back catalogue and new
content to library I've not been
promoting it yet we've picked up about
1100 subscribers so far it looks like it
has legs it's a very cool platform where
people leave tips in an on platform
currency called LBC tokens it works
really well unlike a lot of these
platforms there's a link in the video
description if you're watching this on
youtube you can also just go to lb ry TV
you can either download the desktop
application or you can just access the
content on the website itself it's a
very very cool platform we will be
posting all of our content there
in 2020 and I will probably have more to
say about it upcoming so let me know
should we be on you platform stuff you
want us to add stuff you want us to take
away everything's fine just keep doing
what we're doing always welcome
suggestions send me a tweet at D Pakman
or shoot me an email go to david
pakman.com and use our contact form
would love to hear from you